we continue to add features to ncbi's
genome browser the genome data viewer a
recent addition is the blast widget
which we'll explore in the next two
minutes
you may be surprised to learn that a
good place to start your blast search is
right on the genome data viewer homepage
here you can choose the exact assembly
version that you want to search keep in
mind that this blast interface searches
the top-level sequences that are part of
refseq genome assemblies which number
well over 500 eukaryotic genomes
once you have your blast results you
will see a link to genome data viewer on
the right side of the alignment section
you may also see a link to map viewer
but we will eventually remove that the
gdv ideogram shows you the distribution
of blast hits across the genome notice
the arrow heads the best alignment is
represented by the darkest Arrowhead in
this case on chromosome 15 which is the
alignment that I selected in the blast
results and that sequence is presented
in the sequence viewer portion of the
gdv this is where your blast alignments
show up in blast tracks the best part is
you now have the full functionality of
the genome data viewer including the
ability to add your own track data and a
new feature the blast alignment
inspector which can be launched from
within the blast widget the inspector
allows you to easily examine blast
alignments in a table view or
graphically all the way down to the
sequence level my blast query in this
case was a mouse cDNA so we see many
mismatches in red the blast widget
offers another way to load blast results
by entering a blast or ID number in the
alignment section of the widget you can
sort the alignments and zoom to one or
more selected alignments
at a marker
and filter by percent identity you can
also initiate a new blast to search from
here give the genome data viewer try the
next time you run blast against
assembled genomes
you